♪ ♪
>> Greg: LET'S ADMIT IT,
AMERICA.
WE MISS BARACK OBAMA.
IN A RECENT SPEECH HE SAID HE
HAD NO REAL SCANDALS IN HIS
WHITE HOUSE.
A JAB AT TRUMP.
>> WE DID HAVE A SCANDAL THAT
EMBARRASSED US.
SEEMS LIKE A LOW BAR.
YOU DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT A LOT OF
DRAMA.
>> Greg: NO DRAMA.
TO QUOTE THE TSA OFFICER WHOSE
DOG SNIFFED MY CARRY-ON, LET'S
UNPACK THIS.
WHY DIDN'T YOU HEAR MUCH ABOUT
OBAMA'S WHITE HOUSE?
WHO WAS BRAVE ENOUGH TO LOOK?
NEVER A CLOSER RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND THE
MEDIA.
IF THE WHITE HOUSE WAS A BED,
THE PRESS WAS THE MOTT DOZING.
THEY TOOK AND ATE YOUR SLEEPING
PILL TO WAKE UP WHEN OBAMA'S
POLICIES LEAD TO THE REJECTION
OF THE PARTY IN THE ELECTION OF
TRUMP.
THEY SPRUNG TO ACTION.
IT WASN'T LIKE THERE WEREN'T
SCANDALS UNDER OBAMA.
IRS, BENGHAZI.
THE MEDIA'S BAR WAS SO HIGH IN
TERMS OF INTEREST THEY DIDN'T
EXIST.
NOW YOU HAVE A WOKE PRESS
CHASING DOWN ANY INCIDENT WHERE
TRUMP HAS A BURGER WHOSE CENTER
ISN'T HOT PINK.
OBAMA'S SPEECH WAS AT A
CONFERENCE WHERE PARTICIPANTS
WERE REJECTED IF THEY SHARED ANY
PART OF IT.
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY YOU NEVER
HEARD ABOUT OBAMA?
THERE IS YOUR ANSWER.
COMPLIANCE.
TRUMP'S WHITE HOUSE, THE MOST
TRANSPARENT ENTITY SINCE SCOTCH
TAPE.
THE PRESS SCRAMBLES AFTER HIM AS
IF THEY ARE MAKING UP FOR A LOST
TIME.
LIKE A MAN CLIMBING A MOUNTAIN
AFTER A LIFETIME OF COUCH
SURFING AND PIZZA.
ISN'T IT TRUE, DANA, THAT
OBAMA'S LACK OF SCANDALS WERE
NOT ABOUT SCANDALS BUT A
COMPLIANT PRESS THAT ALLOWED HIM
TO OPERATE IN TOTAL SECRECY.
>> Dana: HAVING BEEN A
REPUBLICAN PRESS SECRETARY, I
WOULD SAY YES, REPUBLICAN
COMMUNICATORS ALWAYS HAVE TO
WORK HARDER.
I ALSO THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
OBAMA SAID IS THERE WERE NO
SCANDALS THAT EMBARRASSED US.
IF YOU ARE NOT CAPABLE OF
EMBARRASSMENT, THEN THAT WOULD
BE TRUE.
THE OTHER THING IS, IT IS TRUE
THAT THERE IS LESS DRAMA.
THERE WAS LESS DRAMA AND THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, LOOKING AT
PERSONNEL ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
BACKBITING IN THE FIRST EIGHT
MONTHS OF THE     THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT ALL OF
THE OBAMA PEOPLE WHO WORKED FOR
HIM, THEY HAVE SAID FROM THE
BEGINNING THAT EVEN AS HE ENDED
HIS PRESIDENCY, THE ONE THING
THEY WERE SO PROUD OF IS THEY
HAD NO SCANDALS.
HE BECAME A WROTE TALKING POINT.
"NO SCANDALS" IS THE NEW "NO
COLLUSION."
EVERYONE SAYS IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AS THOUGH IT WILL FINALLY
SINK IN.
>> Greg: I REMEMBER MSNBC, IF
YOU CRITICIZED PRESIDENT OBAMA,
YOU WERE RACIST.
THAT WAS A GOOD IMMUNE BUBBLE TO
KEEP ANY CRITICISM OR ANYBODY
FROM LOOKING INTO ANYTHING.
>> Jesse: VERY EFFECTIVE.
YOU GLOSSED OVER PRETTY BIG
OBAMA SCANDAL.
THE BIRTH CERTIFICATE WAS HUGE.
OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS A FORGERY.
HE PULLED ONE OVER ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
STILL GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF
THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: YOU WON'T GIVE UP.
>> Jesse: I AM TEASING.
I BELIEVE HIM.
I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT IS ALL ABOUT THE PRESS.
THIS IS BUT THE PRESS SAID ABOUT
BENGHAZI.
IT WAS A REPUBLICAN CONSPIRACY.
THEY DIDN'T PROTECT ONE OF THEIR
OWN AMBASSADORS ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11 AFTER
WARNING SIGNS AND LYING ABOUT
IT.
AND THAT'S A REPUBLICAN
CONSPIRACY?
THEY SAID THE IRS SCANDAL WAS
BIPARTISAN EVEN THOUGH 95% OF
THE GROUPS THAT WERE TARGETED
WERE CONSERVATIVE.
THEY SAID THE AERON DEAL WAS
GREAT DIPLOMACY WHEN THEY      W
GREAT DIPLOMACY WHEN THEY      E
GREAT DIPLOMACY WHEN THEY      S
GREAT DIPLOMACY WHEN THEY      N
GREAT DIPLOMACY WHEN THEY      T
THEM CASH THAT WOUND UP IN
HEZBOLLAH'S HANDS.
WE ARE PASSING OVER THE BERGDAHL
TRADE.
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS IN
TAXPAYER MONEY.
THE VA SCANDAL.
PEOPLE DIED.
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRATS GOT
BONUSES.
I FOUND A LIST OF WHAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SAYS TRUMP
SCANDALS.
READY FOR THESE?
KELLYANNE CONWAY PROMOTED
IVANKA'S FASHION LINE ON TV.
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS STAYED IN
TRUMP HOTELS.
IF THAT IS THE BAR, COME ON.
ANYTHING IS A SCANDAL.
>> Greg: THAT IS A GOOD POINT.
I FORGOT ABOUT THE VA.
WHAT I LEARNED FROM
PRESIDENT OBAMA, MY LIFE WOULD
BE EASIER IF I WAS A LIBERAL.
NO ONE QUESTIONS YOUR
COMPETENCE.
I SHOULD BE A LIBERAL.
MY LIFE WOULD BE EASIER.
>> Juan: YOU WOULD HAVE A HARD
TIME HERE AT FOX.
[LAUGHTER]
I THINK FOX WAS ABSOLUTELY
VIGOROUS IN PURSUING EVERY
BENGHAZI, IRS.
>> Greg: FAIR AND BALANCED.
WE HAD TO.
>> Juan: YOU SAY IT'S A
SCANDAL.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
NITPICKING PIMPLES AND STUMBLING
AND A HUGE ROCK FALLING ON YOU
AND CRUSHING.
THAT'S 19 PEOPLE INDICTED.
FIVE PEOPLE PLED GUILTY.
>> Kimberly: THEY ARE NOT EVEN
LIVING HERE.
>> Jesse: ANY TROUBLE FOR SHOW
PLEAD THE FIFTH OR DESTROY
EVIDENCE?
>> Juan: NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
TRUMP IN THE OVAL OFFICE TALKING
TO RUSSIANS ABOUT NATIONAL
SECRETS.
>> Jesse: WHAT ABOUT REVEREND
WRIGHT?
>> Juan: YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN
NIGER.
FOUR PEOPLE DEAD, NO REPORT,
NOTHING.
YOU ARE DEALING WITH -- HOW
ABOUT ROB PORTER BEATING UP HIS
WIVES.
YOU CAN STAY.
IMAGINE IF THAT -- IMAGINE IF
OBAMA HAD A PERSONAL LAWYER
PAYING OFF PORN STARS?
>> Greg: THAT WOULD BE
IMPRESSIVE.
>> Kimberly: FACT WOULD BE
INTERESTING FOR A LOT OF
REASONS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT YOU HAVE
TO COVER THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
WE ARE COVERING FISA WARRANTS,
HOW THEY WERE OBTAINED, THE
PROPRIETY, THE ETHICS, THE FACTS
AND SUBSTANCE.
WHEN YOU SEE WHAT WE DID HERE,
WE COVERED EVERYTHING IN A
HEALTHY WAY, WHETHER IT WAS
SOLYNDRA, BENGHAZI, FAST AND
FURIOUS, LOIS LERNER.
THERE WAS A PLETHORA.